who's a great practitioner of the
ichimoda team right now shohei ono who's
two-time olympic gold medalist that's
his favorite throw and he there's a tons
of highlight videos on the ijf and
judo fanatic showing how he does his
uchimada and it is quite different than
everybody else's um but it's unstoppable
when he comes in nobody stops it he's
won two goals in a row at the olympics i
think maybe in the last eight years the
guy's lost two matches you know he's
just incredible so at a very competitive
division i guess 73 kilos okay and then
three
three-time world champ too is he the
greatest of all time
do you
the only reason why he's not is because
nomura is a 60 kilo player he was
three-time olympic champion
so no more i mean unless ono is going to
stick around for another three years and
win again and uh
win again here in paris that's you know
then he'd match what nomura did but
three-time gold medalist in judo in a
lightweight division
that's pretty spectacular
so to you the
the being able to win a championship
world championship or olympic medal
is a measure of greatness it's not like
um
you have some people who are not as
accomplished like koga or something like
that but just
the the beauty
uh the the moments of magic the number
of moments of magic is the highest even
if it's not championships i think you
have to go by that because there's so
many phenomenal judo players that have
come through the system of spectacular
judo um
you have one you know countless major
events but you know the ability to pull
it together right at those magical
moments the the pinnacle of the sport
the world championships the olympic
games and proving that you can do it
time and time again
makes you unstoppable it makes you the
best um you know there was a guy back in
the
70s and 80s by the name of fuji and he
won four
world championships back to back and
back then the worlds was every two years
so he was here he was a four-time world
champion that's eight years the top of
the sport he never
uh won an olympic medal
you know he never went to the olympics
you know so there's a guy who missed out
on on olympic greatness but was
arguably the best competitor back in
that that period by the way same
fuji as as fuji
right really okay wow i didn't know that
was an actual guy fuji our brand is is
named after the mountain mount fuji okay
but you know this is a different guy his
name was all right
history rhymes
you